you won essentially the French version
of the Oscar for playing this role which
i think is absolutely first of all
that's got to be an amazing achievement
you went to a French the French Oscars a
French award show which I think must be
very strange because I was white I
watched some of it and the whole thing
is in French as it should be and I
wouldn't have known what the hell was
going on how did you know it was even
happening yeah I went into a meditative
state for that period of time it was a
really long as like four and a half
hours show or something and they don't
have they don't have advertisements or
commercials over in France the way that
we do so we didn't even get to take a
break and like chat and go to the
bathroom and go to drink and an award
shows in America with people watching at
home don't realize is that whenever you
go to a commercial all the celebrities
run out of the room and start drinking
like fish they all rush back in and sit
there
Schloss out of their minds but really
happy but really happy yeah really happy
could you tell what was happening were
you wearing an earpiece I have another
piece for 30 minutes and then it stopped
working and so I was like I didn't even
know when the category came up that it
was mine I had like you know fallen
asleep with my eyes open basically yeah
and then Juliet just screamed in my ear
and was like you was like genuinely do
we have we have the footage of you
winning
you look genuinely surprised and then
you go up on stage and something weird
happens when they try to give you the
award let's talk I have a civil war that
came yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
and you were surprised when you go up
there the guy tries to hand you the
trophy and you said I can't hold it my
hands what was going on there well you
know I was pretty nervous
uh-huh this is it was a bit kind of a
big deal yeah yeah I was joking with my
publicist earlier that day cuz I was
just so nervous I'm so you know
completely fish-out-of-water there
anyway yeah um she was like well
honestly the worst that could happen is
that you win and you have to go hump and
address the nation yes um so I was just
really nervous and I couldn't I played
you know I was like oh you get that
thing where like son I could not open my
hand without this attitude completely
which is embarrassing ridiculous I'm
like trying to open up my one sentence
of French so I could be like and then
you know when I said hey can you just
put that down there I think you didn't
understand me he's French and I think
also infamously kind of like messes with
people oh that guy I thought was just
like it just was acting like an angry
French wait I pissed him off you're like
could you just
that was funny yeah I went to I was in
Finland once at a for an award show for
some reason that I can't even explain
and I didn't know what was happening and
then there was another time where I was
on a German talk-show that was sort of
like this kind of show but they all
spoke German and I had an earpiece and I
would try to make a joke and I'd be like
you know oh whoa then I went my friend
Andy and I we tried to buy a goldfish
but we lost it and you hear like a
spacestation and then no laugh and then
like ten minutes later a laugh that's
completely out of sync with anything
like we don't know that was definitely
about what I said ten minutes ago I
myself felt when I go to sleep tonight
they totally laughed at my joke yeah but
that is it that is it that is a great
that is a great honor where do you keep
the award now or do you just leave it on
the podium BPUT if you when I can't take
it up to her
I don't think I'm just gonna go
you